[Music]
what do you believe
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
I know yes
I had no idea what what this crime was
or how it could possibly work
[Music]
until I started looking into it
thank you
the first thing we knew about sextortion
was a case in Scotland involving a 17
year old lad called Daniel Perry who
apparently received messages through
Facebook
had some money extorted from him
received sums of about 3 000 pounds from
him before he ran out of money
they then carried on threatening him
threatening to release these video
recordings of of him and um
and they started saying to me why didn't
you kill yourself and taunting him even
and um the last message he sent to them
said
I haven't got any more money bye-bye
and he then took his own life
[Music]
when the BNB anti-saver game group was
great that
[Music]
and there was a lot of report of as
extortion happening in the Philippines
victimizing foreign Nationals because of
course International pressure started to
build especially after the death of
Daniel Perry in 2013 and Interpol got
involved
thank you
foreign
[Music]
there was one I suppose a typical victim
a guy in Hong Kong who was working in an
office who was approached on Facebook
and who went off into the office toilets
and had this exchange with somebody he
thought was a woman in the uh in the
Philippines
two hours later they were demanding
money from him
[Music]
you have to rush out of the office and
at the end of the day and try and find a
Western Union branch and send over you
know one sum of money and the next day
another demand came he eventually sent
about two to three thousand pounds or
about three thousand US Dollars before
plucking up the courage to go to the
police and and report it
[Music]
usually you'll find these crimes might
originate in Nigeria or some African
countries and then get copied overseas
but here this was the first that anyone
had ever heard of these crimes being
perpetrated in about 2013 2014 they
suddenly started springing up
this crime didn't exist until Maria
capras invented it the rim leader of a
group of young people who were carrying
out these crimes of extortion and
extorting money from people through
Facebook and getting large sums of money
out of it per Syndicate is thought to
have raped in millions of pounds
huge sums of untraceable money all of
which will be sent to Western Union
accounts
some of the Western Union branches in
the area around where she lived recorded
the biggest takings of any Western Union
branches in the world for a period in
2014 2015. there was so much money
coming in at this time
[Music]
so this operation was named DD operation
Strike Back which resulted to the
Crackdown of these uh Syndicate
syndicated Group which involves in sex
torsion cases
foreign
[Music]
cyber sex extortion
or crime where new to us
it was not that popular yet so the the
impact of this story is alarming
down
[Music]
foreign
they were able to track the movements of
money and all the proceeds were going
through
the two Western Union accounts all owned
by uh the caparas and her Libyan partner
I think they were able to cease a couple
of laptops
hard disk sex toys several Motor
Vehicles including wig
[Music]
nothing
I
told that she was still active on social
media in prison and sent her a message
in Hope rather than expectation saying
I'd like to hear your side of the story
will you let me come and see you in
prison
insisting she was innocent insisting
that another woman in the village was
was the real Kingpin and she was just
being scapegoated
she almost convinced me I mean she told
me that um
she'd been set up she was crying and I
asked her what did you think about the
men who fall for this but you said
they're stupid they're just stupid I
told them I told one or two of them
don't do it again because you've learned
your lesson there so she she could
switch quite quickly and it's clearly
quite
persuasive and highly confident person
probably associate Health you'd probably
describe her as
but for whatever reasons and we can only
suspect what those reasons might be
no case ever came to court and it
appears to have simply dissolved and
kapparas is free and she's got her cars
back too
[Music]
Maria kakaras first started working in
um
centers where Filipino women sort of
strip off and talk to foreigners
let's face it it's a pretty it's a
pretty degrading line of work to find
yourself in and I imagine that's perhaps
where her cynicism about the victims
comes in she's seeing men who are
behaving in a very exploitative Manner
and presumably working with other people
who are being similarly exploited
like a Telemark telemarketing office
call centers you know they're selling
porns they're selling porn sites and
once they they saw an opportunity
someone asking for more and at some
stage we don't know when but clearly a
light bulb went on and she realized how
she could turn this to her Advantage
it's an evil scam but it's a very clever
scam at the same time and it plays on
the fact that people are so ready to
strike up conversations with complete
strangers
[Music]
oh no
problem
Facebook
they will use the Persona of a pretty
young woman
the Persona use will be a younger female
fun-loving a bit silly a bit more fun
and games kind of approach
in social media platforms most of the
information is available
easily they can go to your profile go
through this information go through your
hobbies go through your habits go
through the messages go through the
image videos and all the comments knows
who is your friends
the main goal for them is to make the
account as real as possible okay and why
because they want
the victim to trust them easily
foreign
outside your door and everybody could
easily see it because that time was
something like that was a private
information we are freely posting
information about ourselves and just
give it away give it to the public
giving to the scammers and we just
inviting them to just say this is my
life you want to know anything about my
life here it is and then you can just
have any information about me on my
social media
I believe today there is
um
popular Trend where popularity is above
privacy so the more popular you are the
better it is
but again it's a choice with popularity
and having a public profile comes
everything that relates to that and the
risk associated and that's where social
platforms as are in general a great
platform for criminals in general to
perform their crimes it's an easy way
and they can hide behind a different
um just fake identity
basically they use social media a lot so
they would troll these social media
websites and then interact with people
and they they're fishing for potential
praise
engineer lives in Malaysia engineer
lives in Singapore Hong Kong
um
Facebook
the waste extortion works is that
somebody will send you a friend request
on Facebook somebody you've never met
before
well if you respond to that chat okay
then you can easily be hooked to the
chat
you know a typical legitimate account
you have around
200 300 400 Facebook brands
you know
and statistically when we're trying to
analyze the Facebook account of
criminals you see just around 10 prints
foreign prints coming from everywhere
um
foreign
[Music]
the words to use the emotions to show
the little attentive messages every day
that you can send that that makes
somebody feel good it is in this climate
of trust that they take advantage of the
victim
[Music]
we always assume like those movies like
those Hollywood movies somebody
extremely skillful running some script
and drums running some codes however
that I can say is a 15
of what's happening in a cyber crime
okay the other 85 percent of the cyber
crime practically is nothing to do with
the technical things what we call it
social engineering
engineer is on manipulating people
people in connection with your victim
and try to use that in order to achieve
your crime
[Music]
foreign
and these were mostly teenage boys some
of whom were transitioning to be women
17 years old long
17 18 19
that's the age bracket that normally
that we were able to arrest this
extortion because they they know a lot
about computers
can just pay this jobless teenagers give
them 300 to 500 a day and it will
suffice for them
they you can easily lure them
attract them to this kind of
sex activities
good Chatters would get
um bonuses and extra rewards she shower
them with gifts like iPhones and Samsung
phones all the uh
arrested individuals were minors
HB
[Music]
the surrounding is
much safe safe for them because
there are inadequate
police authorities who operate in the
area
North Hills still looks like a very
ordinary uh Village but somebody pointed
out to me have you noticed what's
different about this Village I can't it
looks like another Filipino Village to
me but they said look at the kids
they're all wearing designer t-shirts
you don't get that in a normal
Philippine Village
she owned a large property in the center
of the village it was like an
entertainment center for the mostly
young people who would work for her and
when we were there there was always
crowds of kids sort of gathering around
them and of course those are the
demographic that would be working for
her or being primed to work for her as
soon as they were a little older foreign
[Music]
trabajo
Platinum
powerful Casino
business
Department
if you ask anybody about Maria caprese
they suddenly suffer from Amnesia and um
are reluctant to talk about it one a
shopkeeper who lives near her house says
everybody knows about what's going on
but nobody will talk to you about it
people are terrified to talk about
what's going on not only terrified but
probably invested as well because
everybody has a son or a daughter or a
brother or a sister somehow involved in
one side of the scam or the other
[Music]
is
foreign
[Music]
technically what she was um what she was
doing
Maria capras came from an extremely poor
background she was living in the slums
in Manila when she first arrived in the
village the neighbors told me she was so
poor she'd have to beg for a bowl of
rice to feed her I know two children she
had nothing at all
she's a Slumdog Millionaire s
effectively she's come from nothing and
become extremely rich in an extremely
dark way
um I got a random Facebook request uh
one night what looked like a attractive
female
foreign
because I didn't know this person at all
at the time I didn't think nothing
I said so we started chatting
uh the second that we got onto the
webcam this person was already removing
their clothing
I did not anticipate this it wasn't that
kind of conversation prior to that I
just thought they wanted to talk
they started removing their clothing
started doing some vulgar things
with toys and stuff like that
started asking me to remove my clothing
I um
I was resisted for a long time for maybe
about 15 minutes
I didn't really know this person I
didn't want to do that I'm not really
into that whole thing either you know
what I mean but eventually I uh I did
and I showed them my private area
[Music]
this person proceeded to stop the video
chat
[Music]
and the screen went completely blank
and once that happened I kind of
realized something wasn't right
through Facebook
oh
foreign
[Music]
she explained to me actually how it all
works
which says that within 20 minutes
the chat gets so intimate
foreign
[Music]
inside
there are pre-recorded videos you know
controlled by key
key points
[Music]
wave your hands
click
two minutes
[Music]
yes
foreign
video
[Music]
play as if
you are really doing it for him
which is
[Music]
foreign
well they don't need to be a I.T experts
or hackers
because all these private information is
already shared in your social media
platform uh for example if you have a
working experience somewhere you already
entered where which locations you work
which company you work they don't want
only you be a Target because all those
friends all those members which they are
in your social media okay it can be a
valuable Target to them that's after you
know the name information
together with the video on tapos
um
and if you can record something and you
can play it over again then the
traumatization
just happens each time you see it
[Music]
is
I know
sell your things
appliances
when you are threatened that these
things will be released publicly you
literally Panic right and and you get
very upset and many of these young
people become very anxious very
depressed on
foreign
[Music]
she had another team of people helping
her produce
fake ID cards with which you go and she
or her lieutenants would go and collect
the money from the Western Union
branches
[Music]
a throughpic ID the way it works is that
to collect these transfers you just need
an ID card that matches the name on the
transfer from overseas and in parallel
to her sex extortion business it appears
that Maria capras had a
cottage industry producing fake ID cards
shop
that is part of this indicate it's much
easier than withdrawing the money from a
Money Shop
that is not owned or part of The
Syndicate so the The Syndicate can
manipulate the transaction and the
release of money but when you trace the
money the details about the ID it's all
fictitious it's a fake idea it's a big
idea definitely
thank you
so for the last decade or so we've been
focusing on making the world more open
and connected and we're not done with
this yet we're always going to do this
uh but I used to think that if we just
gave people a voice and and help some
people connect that that would make the
world a lot better all by itself
and in a lot of ways it has
[Music]
thank you
it's probably the tip of the iceberg
guest we find that about 50 to 60
percent of the scammers do most of their
scamming on Facebook
[Music]
foreign
for the scammers because everything they
need is in the one place they're able to
meet the people there they're able to do
video chat with them there they have
their life there their photographs the
list of their friends and their family
so it's just all encapsulated in the one
place for them
[Music]
I'd say we get around 500 reports a
month which is about 15 a day
[Music]
when we originally started doing this we
were getting around 40 of people coming
to us saying that the scam was from the
Philippines today we get around 55 to 60
percent of them will come from the
Philippines the number one requirement
for a person to involve him or herself
in as extortion is the internet
[Music]
so it can be anywhere in the Philippines
there is no really specific location
they just need a very basic things okay
uh definitely they need some devices
[Music]
this indicates can be anywhere okay they
don't need to be in the certain location
to find the victim in that particular
location they can sit anywhere and the
victim can be Far Far Away there is a
continuous increase of the numbers of
recorded sex torsion cases
[Music]
you could see it from the statistic that
there is an increase of a hundred
percent per year
[Music]
80 of our recorded extortion cases uses
social media there's a huge difference
in investigating a traditional crime
like a simple robbery
a case of homicide or a case of murder
there is a a a gap there's a huge gap on
the procedure of how you will
investigate cyber crime the people do
not know they do not understand that we
cannot just hack into someone's system
and determine who is the person behind
those who is victimizing them
another team the the social media
administrators they're outside the
Philippines they're not here not days
not weeks talks months several months
for us to acquire the information that
we we sought now we we need we need a
lot of information to be able to
identify who's the people behind the
cyber crime so how do we know who we are
in reality talking to
[Music]
we are not able to verify that identity
in a way like we have that possibility
in a physical world there's no need for
verification due to the fact that social
media priority is users adoption they
want more users on their platform we do
not have a worldwide legislation that
can cover those cyber crimes and
criminals know that in some countries
they do not even need to hide because
they know that no one will come and
search for them
[Music]
thank you
Boston
Maybe
[Music]
now
is police
uh Marie Maria capras
um
was quite Brazen about the way she
operated
she also posted pictures of her 13 year
old son
lying down covered in Thousand peso
notes and um lots of other quite overt
pictures
she was very open about the money they
were making
celebrating Christmas and wearing
t-shirts with her name on it calling
them the All-Stars North Hills Village
and with a logo printed on the back
showing her thumb with a cross which is
the sign you get if you're blocked on
Facebook and saying we hate this
I don't see she personally sees any
reason to stop as long as she can
continue getting away with it and all
the signs are that she's going to carry
on getting away with it
she's the queen of sex extortion and
North Hills Village is her fiefdom her
kingdom if you like
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
there's a huge boom in social media
where Wildlife trade was concerned
we started seeing an increase in the
number of people that were actively
participating on social media forums
they were interested in buying and
selling animals they were interested in
asking about animals they wanted to know
prices and we realized that it was
really becoming quite popular
we identified 14 Facebook groups and we
spent 30 minutes a day just 30 minutes a
day to figure out just what level of
activity was taking place on these 14
Facebook groups
thank you
more than 300 animals were being offered
for sale
and we can say that they were being
offered for sale because prices were
mentioned
prices were specifically mentioned in at
least 30 posts
and for just these 30 animals the
community value was about 184 000
Ringgit at that time
I think this is really boils down to a
demand and Supply issue as long as there
is going to be a demand the supply will
consistently be there
[Music]
foreign
we have been doing the best we can in
trying to curb this illegal trade
like
[Music]
tomorrow
but now the illegal Traders themselves
have got very savy they have gone into
cyber space and they are selling their
products through cyberspace and of
course with the invent of Facebook and
advertisement on on internet they are
allowed to spread the information and
they are always when they are biased
there will be people who will break the
law in order to try and again profit by
selling this animal parts and species
that are quite
precious to us
oh
[Music]
it's really quite sad because you hear a
baby crying
[Music]
and somebody's obviously sort of
videoing this whole experience the Box
arrives
the box is opened this little baby in
the box is just wailing all your hair is
a wheel
[Music]
it's about a baby animal
that is stolen from the wild it doesn't
belong in a box it doesn't belong in a
small box it would have been shipped by
post
it had no right to be in that position
you see the problem is there'll be a lot
of uh Bridge guy or what I said I want I
fancy this uh clouded leopard or
something like that
well we'll get around okay this person
wants this
you'd be surprised that most
of these animals are owned by rich
people not the poor will not be able to
afford because they are all in thousands
and all that yeah
when you look at history it was the Rich
and Famous and the royalty that used to
Showcase their animals
and it was always linked with Prestige
status and being somebody
if I can show that I own this animal
then I become now a person of prestige
status acquisition is part of my wealth
part of my trophying right now
the royalties and the kings and queens
would then feature these animals because
everybody was curious to see these
animals
it's probably one of the the early
precursors of zoos and they used to
feature these animals and people used to
come in and watch and observe these
animals and people have this process
where they actually show these animals
their friends and they publicize
in the social media World it means I'm
going to get more likes
if you have a cute fuzzy little animal
that everybody is very excited about
you're going to get a lot of your
friends coming round to your to your
page liking it and it goes viral this is
one of the ways that people are making
themselves more famous by linking
themselves up to exotic animals
to the buyer that somehow is appealing
and that gets posted online it gets a
lot of likes it gets a lot of comments
of course there are a lot of angry
people who say look this is not right
um but clearly that's not what matters
to the buyer
of course as a pet into as a hobbyist
okay we always try to you know get
something different special the interest
that Sparks us to like I want this I
want that
Pet Shops then eventually it was doing
some exhibitions and all that around
Malaysia
[Music]
I've owned numerous headstands so I mean
I mean I have regretted selling some
[Music]
they did a hit count they said there's
probably only
not more than 700 or so hits left in
China and Vietnam this is where this
laser comes from like this is very
sought after in the European countries
or in the states
eventually most of the Hobbies they will
go something higher and they want
something more rare because it will look
cool in the Exotic community
when I was younger so we jumped to it
just the excitement will be able to get
one
on this hobby then you realize that it's
actually
disheartening to see the animal just
dying like that you know that if you
know the know-how you have the husbandry
then the animal could survive
but most of the Traders are just
interested in making money they always
want to sell just to make a quick buck
and that's it and die good you buy back
some more from me
Roblox
[Music]
Italian
foreign
[Music]
uh social media and online platforms
obviously made it really easy
because uh Now by using this technology
they can easily Target the mass Market
they can publish a product
and everybody can get to know it in a
split of second yeah
[Music]
close this is
a Dropship
[Music]
support
sauce online
[Music]
foreign
the account on his side probably is fake
once I mean not his name probably they
use a foreign
[Music]
foreign
young active uh
online
all these platforms right they do have a
timing conditions
it said entertainment condition which
you can't have any illegal activities
okay so this is very clear to the public
however obviously these people
they misuse the platform
and in the same time you can communicate
with them and all these platforms
provide a facility to have a secure and
private chat okay and that makes it more
difficult for investigator to have
access to these chats and identify the
right persons who is behind this animal
trafficking for instance by using
encryption you can easily make a private
chat
and as you know it is impossible to
break the encryption
the biggest challenges is data privacy
and how the platforms makes the data or
makes the communication private
everybody is operating under the cover
of behind the computers on their phone
it's not always easy to identify where
these individuals are
foreign
business from
[Music]
I have some big size albino iguana
yeah it's very tame
shoes
next one recommend the monkeys
mama said right here mama said
[Music]
this is Egyptian Fox this is from Sudan
this is albino Tegu
I do all the legal way I get my license
from pahelitan this is my import
document so export import or we throw
here this is my every bill you see how
many every view is a lot
this is a lot of paperwork
feeding costs
per month 3000 to 5000 and for one years
my Import and Export other charges is
around 40 000 to 50 000 ringgit
[Music]
fit like 10 000 Ringgit or below ten
thousand or fifteen thousand each
reptiles and each animals they need the
microchips microchip you pay about 10 to
15 Ringgit for each animals
we have to pay the Box charges and
handling fees it's about 2 000 to 3000
US dollars
delicious
is this illegal or illegal of course
Hong Kong
this owl I think is a white face
it's no mistake which one is legal and
illegal no legal no legal ah no legal
uh konkan slow loris no no legal
author no legal I love this illegal
monkey
not suitable to keep
you see all the people there catch and
they are try to make money
I think this is illegal way they are
coming in
how are the illegal usual illegal ways
that they come in the first thing is if
a legal way they have a proper box
for the shipping
because this is
we can't see anything inside so we don't
know the inside is what animal is is it
so
this is I'm sure the illegal they are
doing
foreign
[Music]
caption
snake for sale you can just put
something to attract people like very
rare species or good for beginners you
can say good deal no no hassle donate
license so you know something like that
it's easy then you get people who wants
exotic pets or whatever they will go
through it you know probably you know by
tomorrow or so somebody might just pick
it up or anything like that
now in a way it's easy because you don't
need you don't need a shop you won't get
busted you should say so you have you
can do a lot of fake accounts and all
that
there's a lot of ways you can WhatsApp
escape the
law
the seller why is that you have three
hateful heads before he comes
normally the Trappers are based away
from the city you know so for the seller
it must be feasible for him to travel
there to collect
[Music]
for example a monkey falling behind the
ringgit he will probably be selling to
the
the buyer the potential buyer at about
two thousand or three thousand four
hundred Ringgit product he can make so
much see that's why he will take the
risk
because it's like more than 10 full of
the profits
he was equivalent to a down payment for
a small house in Malaysia so we're not
talking about 10 Ringgit or 20 Ringgit
we're really talking about hundreds and
thousands of ringgit
[Music]
the million tiger is very specific in
the sense that is only found in
Peninsula Malaya
we are putting a large effort in order
to conserve the Tigers in Malaya we only
have about less than 200 of them but you
know tiger parts now is a worldwide
market
and people come in here just looking for
tigers in order to put the snares and
catch them
because one tiger can be sold for
anywhere between 150 000 U.S to 200 000
us and every part of the Tigers used in
order to to to sell and make a profit so
there are people in our jungles who have
come from Vietnam who have come from
Cambodia in Laos and including locals
who are hunting them
[Applause]
the total of confiscated Iris consists
of
3692 kilograms of whole and partial pass
and 228 kilogram of semi-finished
products
this task is heavy
of course there's a bit made of the Dust
not that very beautiful but this is
heavy
foreign
[Music]
thank you
bada
young adults
some other
foreign
most people were actually able to find
everything so we have to do a better job
of hiding suffering yeah maybe create
more secret Pockets inside
so what we're going to show you is how
Smugglers commonly smuggle things on
their persons
most common when they are traveling by
air for example this is an egg vest
people have been caught trying to
smuggle eggs on themselves sometimes
it's on their body sometimes it's
strapped on their legs keeps them nice
and warm and doesn't set up any metal
detectors so everything goes through
quite smoothly
sometimes you also have these specially
modified
vests or jackets in here
fake of course ivory
additional pockets
you can carry pretty much anything as
long as it is not metal it doesn't set
off metal detectors and if you add more
clothes you get a little bit puffy you
don't set any alarm Bells off
and
this is an example of how Tauruses are
frequently smuggled and they're all
tipped to prevent them from moving
every single one of them alive because
it's for the pet train
another example birds in a bottle and if
you go online in Google you'll find many
many pictures of birds being smuggled
like this you've got holes let them
breathe but one of the easiest and
fastest ways to smuggle Birds
book with a surprise in it
who doesn't like a book
but inside you've got a
gecko
and these are all actual examples of how
Smugglers have been arrested we are
seeing a lot of our native animals being
exported for sale elsewhere in the world
we are also seeing non-native animals
coming into the country and so if you've
got this Dynamics as a source and as a
consumer as well as a Transit country
for things that aren't really targeted
to local demand we're not saying that
this is a problem here in Malaysia this
is a global problem
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
hours in the morning
definitely they have Mercedes and
homemade guns
[Music]
mostly two or three percent because if
you get a big animal you cannot handle
alone you cannot carry it alone
purchase this too to type I mean for
purchase is like it's either for food
or for the pet
everything is worth money any Wildlife
can be sold
[Music]
we found BB Gibbons
we found baby sun bears it's really
quite shocking they were animals that
were considered totally protected under
the wildlife conservation Act of
peninsula Malaysia a number of these
individuals are actually offering
animals that you cannot sell
[Music]
the more worrying question is how on did
these individuals get these animals the
vast majority of them were native
animals which means people were going to
the forest they were trapping them and
what's really surprising even more
shocking about this was that almost all
of them were juvenile animals
and particularly for mammals it's a it's
a pretty serious problem when you take a
baby away from its mother from its
family you don't know how long they will
survive their own support system in the
wild has been essentially taken away
[Music]
foreign
survive
they had no respect for projecting
species in the wild they had no respect
for law enforcement in the authorities
it was it was a crime pure and simple
because they knew for a fact that they
were offering animals that they were not
supposed to offer for sale
[Music]
near me
foreign
ah
[Music]
Stacy hey
is there a little bit individuals
[Music]
complex program
um directly
the negative
um
[Music]
running
foreign
[Music]
World Wildlife day I'm declaring war
against the Fortress the time has come
to stop the killing of the Millennium
tigers
and the other Wildlife by these ruthless
quotas we we have continuous programs
whereby a special committee has been set
up
and whatever information that we have
that we we pick up and our our cyber
crime unit whereby they know how goods
are being transferred from one area to
another
that is when we call in all these people
who are involved
[Music]
foreign
from International agencies who have
experiences in this and they are also
advising us
foreign
[Music]
that will deter them from coming in and
trying to approach our animals in from
the from the forest
foreign
[Music]
to have make sure that the deterrent for
those who break the law uh the
punishment is equal equally severe and
they won't attempt to do it so these
laws are in place are being there and I
think uh by 2020 we would see a lot of
amendments taking place as far as the
ministry is concerned
so my message to them is we are coming
be prepared and we have given others
what to do and if you're caught you will
pay heavily for the crime that you have
committed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]